[Music]
we know you're very busy was very nice
of you to run over from the set when is
an anchorman 2 coming out what's coming
out later on in the year I mean like
late I think maybe in December it's it's
uh it's been hard because we can't
really talk about it you know there
people ask those questions but right
it's all on lockdown what's in the
script what's gonna happen however I was
able to talk to Adam McKay the director
and the studio and they were I did get a
little clip of something that we shot in
the first week and I thought maybe we
could show it you're gonna show that
right now this is crazy all right he's
gonna go crazy viral let's take a look
at this clip from anchorman anchorman 2
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you've been showing that stupid clip on
my show thank you for I think 15 years
thanks from a movie called Mac and me oh
and you always convinced me you're not
going to show it again and you promised
me you're not going to show it again and
you show it again I couldn't pass up the
opportunity and III apologize thank you
for doing that
I actually do have a clip but I wanted
to do that well at least one more time I
mean that Lana I had to at least you
know get it out there all right all
right
but I actually did have yet you do have
one okay let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
get out
you're a really bad guy
[Applause]